now let's do something pretty
interesting this will some degree one of
the easiest functions to find the
maclaurin series representation of but
let's try to approximate e to the x
f of x is equal to e to the x and what
makes this really simple is when you
take the derivative and this is frankly
one of the amazing things about the
number e is when you take the derivative
of e to the x you get e to the x
so this is equal to f prime of x this is
equal to f
the second derivative of x this is equal
to the third derivative of x this is
equal to the nth derivative of x it's
always equal to e to the x that's what's
that's kind of the first mind-blowing
thing about the number e that's it's
just you could keep taking its
derivative the slope the slope at any
point on that curve is the same as the
value of that point on that curve that's
kind of crazy anyway with that said
let's take its maclaurin representation
so we have to find f of 0 f prime of 0
the second derivative at 0. when you
take e to the 0
e to the 0 is just equal to 1. and so
this is going to be equal to f of 0 this
is going to be equal to f prime of 0
it's going to be equal to
any of the derivatives any of the
derivatives evaluated any of the
derivatives evaluated at zero the nth
derivative evaluated zero and that's why
it takes that's why it makes applying
the maclaurin series formula fairly
straightforward if i wanted to
approximate e to the x using a maclaurin
series
so e to the x
and i'll put a little approximately over
here and we'll get closer and closer to
the real e the x as we keep adding more
and more terms and especially if we add
an infinite number of terms it would
look like this f of 0
f of zero let me do it in what colors
did i use first cosine and sine so i
used
pink and i used green so let me use a
non-pick non-green i'll use the
yellow here
so f of zero is one
plus f prime of 0 times x f prime of 0
is also 1. so plus
x
plus this is also 1 so it's going to be
x squared over 2 factorial so plus x
squared over 2 factorial this all of
these things are going to be one this is
one this is one when we're talking about
e to the x so you go to the third term
this is one you just have x to the third
over three factorial plus x to the third
over three factorial i think you see the
pattern here we just keep adding terms x
to the fourth over four factorial plus x
to the fifth over five factorial plus x
to the sixth over six factorial and
something pretty neat is starting to
emerge
is that e to the x one this is just
really cool that e to the x can be
approximated by one plus x plus x
squared over two factorial plus x to
third over three factorial once again e
to the x is starting to look like a
pretty cool thing this also leads to
other interesting results that if you
wanted to approximate e you just
evaluate this at x is equal to one this
isn't so this is so if you wanted to
approximate e
you'd say e is approximate to e well e
is e to the first power and that's going
to be approximately equal to this
polynomial evaluated at one if x is one
here we make x one over here so it'll be
one plus one so it'll be one plus one
plus
1 over 2 factorial plus 1
over 3 factorial plus 1 over 4 factorial
so on and so forth all the way into
infinity and you could view this as you
could also view this as 1 over 1
factorial as well
1 over 1 factorial but what's really
cool is this is another really neat way
to represent e it shows that e once
again shows up in this kind of neat
thing it's kind of 2 plus
1 half plus 1 6 plus if you just keep
doing this you get close to the number e
but that by itself isn't the only
fascinating thing
if we look back at our maclaurin
representations of these other of these
other functions cosine of x let me copy
and paste cosine of x
so cosine of x right up here
so let me do my best to i'll copy and
paste the whole thing
so copy
and paste
copy
and paste so that is cosine of x
and let's do the side the same thing for
the sine of x that we did last video
so the sine of x
so sine of x let me copy and paste that
copy
and then
let me paste that
edit paste
so do we see any relationship between
these approximations so before you know
you probably would have guessed maybe
there's some relationship between cosine
and sine but what about e to the x
and what you see here
is that cosine of x looks a lot like
this term
plus this term although we would want to
put a negative out front here so it's a
negative version of this term right here
plus this term right here plus a
negative version of this term right over
here
and sine of x
sine of x looks just like
this term
plus a negative version of this term
plus
this term
plus a negative version of the next term
so if we can somehow reconcile the
negatives in some interesting way it
looks like e to the x is somehow or at
least its polynomial representation of e
to the x is somehow related to a
combination of the polynomial
representations of cosine of x and sine
of x so this is starting to get really
really really cool we're starting to see
a connection between something related
to compound interest or a function
whose derivative is always equal to that
function and these things that come out
of the unit circle and oscillatory
motion and all of those things there
starts to see seem some type of pure
connectedness here but i'll leave you
there in that video and in the next
video i'll show you how you can actually
reconcile these these three fascinating
functions